well china's launched an official
protest with the german embassy in
beijing that's after foreign minister
analina berbak criticized chinese
aggression towards taiwan on monday
after a speech to the u.n she said
germany stands united with the u.s we
share american concerns
we have painfully learned over the past
months with february 24th that
aggressive rhetoric can turn into
dangerous action
china's comments with regard to taiwan
raise serious questions
it cannot be in our interest if china is
creating
on top of this
excessive economic dependency in its
region
well dw correspondent michaela kufner
was at an elena bear box speech in new
york and she described what the foreign
minister had to say regarding nancy
pelosi's visit to taiwan and how those
comments came to upset china
she said that it simply wasn't
acceptable in relation to russia that a
bigger state could attack a smaller
neighbor and that international law also
applies to china now that didn't go down
well a protest was delivered to the
german ambassador in beijing
and um clearly this just shows the
chinese reflex when there is criticism
although we have learned
out of the background here that there is
no interest to really make a clear
statement a reaction on that visit
it appears just like the united states
they want to see this visit speak for
itself and not add fuel to the fire
because quite clearly what we are seeing
from the chinese side there is quite a
bit of anger over this visit
now the foreign minister also called for
strengthening of the the transatlantic
alliance what does she mean by those
words
yes well she held a speech on seizing
the transatlantic moment
that is a rather nice way of saying of a
rediscovery of transatlantic bonds the
reliance on the united states in the
light of the ukraine war and
she there says that china is of course a
common concern um
more alignment with the u.s policy on
china is what she's hinting at and that
could mean taking a tougher stance but
that could also mean after the failure
to get that transatlantic trade
agreement together that there could be
individual steps that could amount to
something like a closer trade framework
now the foreign minister also said that
germany had abandoned its long-held
belief in the concept of change through
trade what does she mean by that
um
this is very interesting because this is
the question that uh
uh angela mackel the former german
chancellor avoided during those final
months of being in office when she was
asked with the example of china whether
that was proof that true that this
concept had failed she simply didn't
want to answer that very question um
here analina berbock stating that quite
clearly and what she means is having
less trade reliance she cited ukraine um
with germany's europe's heavy reliance
on russian gas
as a negative example and in relation to
china
that must mean
she is her argument how to have less
dependence in certain aspects of
production uh supply lines not to have
to discover that there can't be any
certain medicines so it can can no
longer be delivered
at home because of a high reliance on
china so reducing that i think there she
is very much in line
with what america both under trump and
underbide and has been calling for for a
long time clearly the europeans the
germans are rethinking their trade
relations to china okay thank you for
that dw correspondent mikhaila kufner in
new york